9 octobre 1981 il ya 40 ans la dette est
historique sous l'impulsion de robert
badinter alors garde des sceaux la peine
de mort est abolie en france mais très
vite des français demandent son
rétablissement mars 1982 une bijoutière
est assassiné à paris la colère monte
du côté de la classe politique certaines
personnalités entendent aussi relancé le
débat notamment à l'extrême droite
ecoutez jean marie le pen alors
président du front national c'était en
1984 attention petit lapsus au passage
je suis effectivement un partisan de
lapine de la peine demain et je suis
partisan de l'application de la peine de
mort quatre ans plus tard en 1988 une
manifestation est organisée par le front
national à paris en faveur du retour de
la peine capitale à la tribune encore
jean marie le pen a établi aujourd'hui
dans notre pays la peine de mort c'est
signer
à droite aussi des politiques veulent
revenir en arrière
1988 toujours une proposition de loi est
déposé par des membres du rpr à
l'assemblée nationale parmi eux le
sénateur charles pasqua à société a le
droit de se défendre et je crois que le
moment est venu de
montrer grâce aussi était décidé à
utiliser tous les moyens et moi je suis
partisan dans ce domaine du
rétablissement
mais le débat ne s'arrête pas là des
français continue de revendiquer le
retour de la peine de mort comme
l'association légitime défense écoutez
les propos de l'un de ses membres en
1989 dans son viseur l'ancien ministre
de la justice robert badinter je les
considère comme des assassins se sont
eux ce sont les pourvoyeurs des
assassinats des assad et des assassins
de nos gosses pour moi ce sont des
receleurs ce sont les malfaiteurs se
sont endettés de la pègre des années
passent et certaines affaires
criminelles sont aussi un prétexte pour
demander le retour de la peine capitale
exemple en 1997 après le meurtre de
quatre jeunes femmes dans le
pas-de-calais par deux marginaux ça veut
dire quoi le ruban blanc ces
sept ans plus tard en 2004 nouvelles
revendications l'espagne frappée par les
attaques terroristes
encore une fois en france c'est un
prétexte pour revenir en arrière 47
députés ump déposent une proposition de
loi pour le retour de la peine de mort
mais uniquement pour les terroristes la
question c'est de dire effectivement
quelqu'un qui a commis un acte je veux
dire monstrueux comme ceux qui ont
déposé des les bons d'achat eh bien ces
gens là ils méritent d'être exclue
l'humanitaire aujourd'hui la peine de
mort reste un sujet clivant en france
même quarante ans après son abolition
55% des français étaient pour son
rétablissement selon un sondage de
septembre 2020
[Musique]